hey everyone welcome we are at the
blockchain economic forum we are
currently with C Mohan mmm how are you
glad to meet you and have this chitchat
with you thank you for coming out of the
show okay greatly appreciate it thank
you so let's talk about your background
you have 36 years at IBM that's right
that's a big stuff yep
so it was since I finished my PhD from
the University of Texas at Austin in
December 81 I've been at IBM research
technically all the time in Almaden but
physically I've been in Europe for a
year I did a sabbatical at indriya the
French computer science Research
Institute that was 98 99 and then from
the middle of 2006 to early 2009 I was
based in Bangalore and I was the IBM
India chief scientist but all the time
my home base was the IBM Research Lab in
San Jose and this is the birthplace of
relational the sequel language and also
hard destroys and at a manipulation okay
that's a lot right there okay okay
hard disk drives atom manipulation
database and queries okay so let me see
if we can try and unpack this the better
understand it okay so we store data and
then we access the data and then there
are certain ways to increase the
efficiency of accessing the data so the
reliability of the storage of the data
various kinds of indexing schemes to
efficiently access the data we used to
have of course as part of IBM the hard
disk drive manufacturing operations also
so my research lab had a lot of people
working on even the physical aspects of
the distractor we still do the research
but the manufacturing and all that of
the destroy technology hard this drive
technology we sold it off to hit achieve
quite a while ago but we still have the
people that work on the storage software
like the EMC kind of things happening in
IBM and we are also still having within
IBM even tape drive manufacturing and
associated research and we do have
physicists and chemists and such people
that work on materials and such even
though IBM sold off to Global Foundries
the actual fabs and such that you used
to have in fiscal and Vermont so one of
the interesting ways that biotechnology
can work with computation is through
storing the digital data in DNA that's
very exciting so there are various
interesting kinds of topics that are
completely outside of my own domain of
research work that other people in my
lab work on in fact an alumnus of my own
AIT a guy who was one year junior to me
he is the director of science and
technology at IBM Almaden and his people
work on new materials and even new
membranes and things like that to do for
instance elimination of salt from
seawater and things like that and also
people work on quantum computing and
things like that these are the sorts of
things that I know very little about
what's the lab called it it used to be
called the IBM San Jose research lab
when I joined back in 81 that was the
time when we were in one location in San
Jose and then in the summer of 1986 we
moved to the current facility which I'm
it's on the top of the hill in Almaden
Valley at that time the name was changed
to IBM muhammadin Research Center and so
this is the second largest IBM research
lab after the headquarters lab which is
the TJ Watson Research Center in
Westchester County in New York area Wow
second largest Wow so there's the IBM
research lab versus Almaden the Watson
Research Lab the Almaden Research Lab so
what about your work at the Almaden
Research Lab over these last couple
things especially this most recent
coolest things that you're very excited
about we'd love to learn off sure I mean
over the decades I've worked on various
aspects
for database systems in particular the
sort of the bottom layer of a database
system which has to do with concurrency
control recovery transactions how to
manage the data in a way that
reliability of the storage of the data
is guaranteed and even when failures do
happen hope to efficiently recover from
them how to provide more granular
concurrent access to the data those are
the sorts of things I've worked on also
in the distributed context not just in a
single system context we stopped there
for betting and learning about this we
have both reliability and granularity
senses of access yes intently allowing
multiple transactions to get at the data
not just to read but also to modify the
data while still guaranteeing the
consistency of the data so that people
don't get confused and the data is
mutual consistency is not compromised
meaning for instance if you're moving
money from one account to another
you don't want to get into the situation
where due to a failure at the wrong time
the money gets pulled out of the first
account but it doesn't get deposited
into the second account so you have to
guarantee the thomas city of operations
that touch multiple pieces of data and
so we call it asset property of
transactions and on top of it if you
told somebody that the transaction had
done its job and then the system fails
we have to ensure that after we come
back whatever the story might have been
before the failure in terms of whether
or not the changes you made to the
database got written to the persistent
storage namely disk or not you still
have to ensure since you gave the return
code to the user saying that particular
transaction had quote-unquote committed
we need to now reestablish
the fact that the transaction committed
by recreating that update if in fact the
changes were made to the in-memory
version of the database and it had not
been written to disk but the log had
been written so we use the log records
written during normal transaction
processing to make sure that any changes
that didn't make it to the position
storage are reconstructed using the
redundant information of the log so it's
these sorts of things that I personally
have worked on but a more recent
exciting thing I've been doing for about
a year and a half now it's my foray into
the area of block chains and bringing
into the blockchain world some of the
mainstream database ideas and in
particular what I'm working on is to add
relational database support in the high
polish of fabric which is the particular
system that IBM had lot to do with in
terms of leadership in the blockchain
space in particular the permissioned or
private blockchain space where this is
before I got involved a bunch of IBM was
built a prototype and then IBM worked
with the Linux Foundation to create this
new consortium called hyper ledger
you know brian behlendorf yeah
so we then seeded that foundation that
consortium with fabric as the first
project now there are of course many
projects IBM itself for instance more
recently contributed sauce cord that was
based on work done within IBM and
instituted sort of initiated the new
project called composer which allows you
to more easily develop blockchain
applications for deployment with fabric
so composer and it may makes it easier
for people to develop blockchain
applications
the hyper ledger found a composer okay
and then also you were mentioning
something to me earlier about the
ability to access rather than needing to
download the entire blockchain of all
different transactions that have
occurred previously just to be able to
maybe view or to know what the
granularity at eveything was a bit
different what I was saying was today
the fabric lets you model the assets
that are being managed using blockchain
technology by making use of originally
what was called leveldb a simple key
value store and more recently with
version 1 they are also optionally
allowing you to use CouchDB as the
database system to manage the latest
states of the assets that are being
managed using the blockchain technology
so the broad chain it's sort of the
history of all the changes that you
spend but the latest state is kept in a
state database and learnt that state
databases modeling primitives are very
primitive so what do we mean by modeling
so the so we have a blockchain for
whatever record it is let's say diamonds
or let's say diamonds yes of whatever
the good or services so then there's
this blockchain and then the modeling
that we do of it is for purposes of
being able to see it and experience it
get information from it in ways that's
not too complex and too convoluted but
easy to understand I also you know if
it's a package you have various
attributes right how big the package is
what it's volume is what the wave might
be and who wants it there are various
properties of whatever that sets are and
the question is are you modeling those
properties explicitly so that the
database system is aware of these
different attributes or does
treat all the attributes as a black box
and all it knows is oh this particular
object has this ID but the database
system itself doesn't know exactly what
the different properties are just just a
bag of bits that then puts the burden on
the guy who writes the smart contract
having to have its own way of figuring
out what the constituents of that bag of
bits are then is it fair to say that we
can assign variables to represent us we
as you can then refer to them in your
statements data manipulation statements
as well as data retrieval statements and
say hey give me those objects where the
weight is higher than this those sorts
of queries are not easily supported
today but that would make it so that I
would have to mark every time that there
was a piece of information recorded on
the blockchain that I wanted to stamp it
with a certain variable I would have to
stamp it with the variable newsies it's
a question of you know once you model
for instance the containers using a
relational table there is a schema
that's associated with it and so as you
insert information you will provide the
different attributes values there may be
some attributes for which you don't know
the value in which case it can be a null
value so easy and yeah it is easy to
yeah the sequel kind of language that's
our own that's been around for 40 years
which was originally developed in my
research lab by my predecessors that
makes it all very easy to do and there
are you know gazillion people out there
who were well versed in the sequel
language and so it it's also a way to
ensure that the consistency of the data
and all that is preserved this is you
know like preaching to the choir kind of
thing because the benefits of relational
technology and higher level query
languages and all those sorts of things
have been
well understood for decades and so come
little just more Center we'll just
enable all that to be the case and so
it's no different from developing
traditional kinds of sequel applications
when it comes to doing this sort of
thing in the blockchain context also so
it's amazing efficiency in relational
databases in squaring the databases
especially with blockchain technology
now making it even more easy for us to
access and model the data well it's to
be benefiting from all the advantages of
blockchain way of managing information
and prominence and all that this will
also make it possible to do analytics on
the blockchain data much better than
it's possible today you don't have to
for instance move the data out of the
blockchain on to a more traditional
database system in order to do analytics
you can still do in-place analytics so
what that means is in the good old days
even in the relational database context
and so on
you add this concept of an online
transaction processing system where the
bread-and-butter transactions which are
of short duration which bring in money
directly and so on
we'll get performed and then you left a
separate database system which might be
indexed differently and things like that
where you will be able to do analytics
and periodically the data will get moved
from the online transaction processing
systems database system to the data
warehouse as I just called or the data
Mart and this meant that there was a
delay between the time something got put
into the OLTP system and the time it
became available in the so called OLAP
system model yeah the query and do
analytics and things like that and maybe
see trends in the pattern of now you can
write all that so this is the sort of
thing that for instance
is thought of as possibly the reason why
he and some of the problems in 2008
where during the daytime traders might
have been making some decisions about
work loans to approval where to make
investments and so on based on how much
money was at risk as of last night and
so in parallel multiple traders based on
the same out-of-date data only from last
night yeah not from a year ago from just
12 hours yeah even that if in
simultaneous while people are making
decisions which is putting lot more
money at risk because they are not
seeing each other's today's so
investments and such then out of date
data is now 12 hours ago that's crazy
even like an hour goes out of day later
because of the speed at which you are
making decisions and the number of
people making decisions and the amount
of money that's being invested or loaned
out whatever the situation is that you
are dealing with so what is currently as
a result popular is this concept of HT
ap which is hybrid transactional and
analytic processing the idea being
instead of having two separate database
systems one for the oil keeping online
transaction processing workload and
another one which is containing data
derived from the OLTP system which is
the OLAP system online analytical
processing system and thereby also
incurring the cost of having two copies
of the data yes right oh yeah and as the
data becomes big data the installation
cost is predominantly storage cost
rather than the CPU cost and so on so by
now making hybrid the possibility of
doing transactional workload as well as
the analytic workload against the same
database system you get multiple
benefits but it has its share of
technological difficulties so it's
that's why some of us have been
researching this topic for a few years
now
and I've been involved in that work also
prior to my involvement with blockchain
and as a result of the work done in IBM
research as well as in the product
groups we put out a product called the
db2 event store last year and which has
the ability to ingest lot of data pretty
fast and still provide transactional
guarantees while at the same time making
that data available yeah within like a
second after the data enters the system
or even fancier than that for the query
and so you can combine the benefits of
OLTP as well as even OLAP queries
systems like spark and such in this
context so this is very relevant in the
context of IOT as well as mobile
computing arena
oh yeah and payments yes so you want to
be able to for instance so as you're
wandering around wandering around a
shopping mall or whatever ads might be
shown to you and based on what ads you
see or what sites you follow or clicks
you do on your mobile phone we want to
dynamically decide what new ads to show
keep track of what has just mean shown
so that you don't get bored of seeing
the same thing and so on so so a lot of
these sorts of use case scenarios have
become important in the new world of you
know everybody running around with
smartphones and things like that in this
instant economy that we live in the
instant data flow that we need to be
able to better understand how things are
moving around and how to maximize
efficiency volume of data and the amount
of data that gets generated because so
many people are mobile and all that so
and the relatability and modeling and
querying it that's so this is amazing in
the physical location of the person and
everything else also so you might be
walking you might be running you might
be in a
and things like that so so various
developments over the last decade or so
bring about these different requirements
and also the need for different types of
workloads then the good old days when we
used to talk about just OLTP are all app
and the transaction processing council
came up with benchmarks which had either
the transactional characteristic or the
analytics characteristics and now we are
seeing more and more a combination of
these things having to be worried about
yes
what are you most looking forward to
with blockchain technology well I mean
clearly there is of course too much
hoopla with respect to crypto currencies
and the permissionless blockchain world
where as I and lots of other people who
are much more practically minded and
think about the industrial-strength
kinds of situations and what are some
day so yeah so I mean IBM of course has
been well known for the last many years
in being a leader and the permissioned
or private blockchain space and so some
of the well discussed use case scenarios
for which for quite a while there was
prototyping activity and some of these
things have now even become actually
deployed in production more kind of use
cases have to do with things like food
safety farm-to-fork where we worked with
Walmart for instance we are about to
release some products in that space less
UV we've also worked with Maersk on
logistics container movements across the
globe Merce being the world's largest
shipping company
so you saw just a chime in along the way
so you said with food safety now so
these industrial applications the ones
that are maybe a little bit more closer
to our hearts the ones that are more
applicable to us such as understanding
that we're where the food is coming from
and being able to make sure that it came
from this farm that it went through this
tracking process to get to this store
that then you purchased it from whether
it was truly organic or not and more
importantly really beyond all of those
is the fact that if there is some
problem some poisoning this that happens
we want to be able to do provenance
tracking in a way where we can limit the
amount of recall and all that that needs
to be done and this applies even in the
components industry in automotives and
so on the airbag being faulty or
seatbelt being faulty and such things we
can more precisely know it was this
particular batch of seatbelts that were
manufactured in this particular factory
of this particular manufacturer that was
the one that is not yea working right
and hence if we know exactly which
specific instances of cars had those
faulty ones then we can limit the recall
to just those things and there are other
applications where iBM has been working
with the Center for Disease Control or
the Food and Drug Administration which
have to do with you know implementing
some of the HIPAA regulations which can
which relate to personally identifiable
information and who had access to wort
and whether the information was released
only for the purposes for which the
providers of the information gave them
or they are being misused and you know
you sure heard about all these fake news
and this and that and some of the
facebook information being misused and
things like that yes so many things of
that nature also in terms of you know
access rights control and things like
that can be better done with the more
rigorous manner in which the blockchain
technology lets you track the state
changes that happen to whatever the
assets are the assets could be purely
digital assets or they could be the
digital representations of physical
assets you you Mohan you're targeting
one of the big ones that I think we love
talking about it's the request for
access to access control of certain
pieces of data and being able to very
intelligently visibly transparently map
where that access is going who's taking
it what they're using it for what their
credentials are and you know what they
need to know is and things like that so
by having the identity of the people in
the ecosystem being known rather than
like in the end blockchain system where
it's anonymous or pseudonymous here we
will be able to do a lot more and some
of the problems that you deal with in
the open block chain space where the
absence of identity of the participants
being known you wind up having to worry
lot more about Byzantine behavior but a
malevolent glare exactly people who
intentionally try to mess up things and
so on that's less of a problem in the
permission blockchain arenas where
clearly because your good behavior
incentivization in order for you to know
the identity of them and your issuing
certificates and so on
it isn't not too different from the uber
or the a B&B kind of situation where
even if you and I as the end consumers
of these services don't know the whole
history of the people involved the
drivers are the renter's of the space
the company uber or Airbnb has lot more
of the
mission about the individuals involved
that they know and so even if there are
obviously instances where people do some
bad things sooner than later they'll be
identified and yes appropriate actions
will be taken this also reminds me a lot
of the sort of I was we were just at the
blockchain for social justice conference
this last weekend and we were learning
about how it is crazy to think about
with manifest destiny happening and
people coming and taking over vast
swaths of land over the history of
civilization people expanding their
borders over time that if people just
had better tracking of the land and then
what ones who owns what what would have
it looked like what would our world look
like today if that was the case and so
it's so interesting that now with this
technology
how will borders ever expand again if
they will ever expand again or decrease
again so you mentioned a lot of really
groans food health so many other ones
with of health care logistics was a huge
one so so that's all we love talking
about that I'm really happy that you
care so much about seeing that future
with blockchain we are gonna end with a
couple really quick questions that we
asked on the show a lot one of the
questions we asked on the show a lot is
what are we going to do about wealth
inequality because it's because the rich
are getting much much richer faster with
exponential technology and the poor are
only very slowly coming up so what do
you think so I mean one of the benefits
of the blockchain technology even in
that space would be and countries like
India are trying to also leverage
blockchain for such reasons which has to
do with more transparency about what is
happening where and when and by omens on
and you could also eliminate more of the
middleman in many situations rip off the
poor people by acting as middlemen and
they take away big chunks of the money
that for instance the government might
be subsidizing the poor people's
livelihoods in vary by various means in
the case of India even liquid
petroleum gas and such things were
subsidized but because the end consumers
were not necessarily you know the banked
population they didn't have bank
accounts or credit cards a lot of times
these intermediaries in the guise of
providing the means to get the money
from the government these poor people
we're taking a big chunk of it so by
having in the case of India at least the
concept of other card this national
identity scheme and also by going to
more and more electronic payments and
things like that they are able to with
pay TM is one of the technologies yeah
they are able to eliminate the wastage
that happens and the reduction and
benefits that actually finally reach the
poorer people and so it's I believe
things like that that will be the ones
that will help the poorer sections of
society and of course you know in this
context it's also important to make sure
that things like the unregulated icos
and all that though cause not just the
bluffing but you you bring up the the
benefit of eliminating the third parties
because they do sometimes take
exorbitant fees for the transactions and
everything and that hurts poor
middle-class people but at the same time
it's also there's lots of schemes going
on in the space and that's helping a lot
of people make away with lots of money
right now so I also think there's a very
interesting give-and-take there on both
sides of the equation okay next question
is do you think that we are alone in the
cosmos oh my god I'm the kind of guy who
is unable to relate to all those things
about millions of light years away or
things that happened billions of years
ago and things like that so I go a
little crazy even though I'm a scientist
at heart and I have forever been a
technical guy so I'll leave it up to the
people who are better
informed or you know knowledgeable about
who do you feel the only I I don't know
I mean it's when I look at this guy I
just can't relate to those things that
are so far away that my imagination it's
not you know you know when I look up at
the sky I see the other earth orbiting
the star I see a little mohanam o on
that rock say one moment is enough for
the worse it's not we need 10 pretty 10
moments in universe
okay how about do you think that we are
in a simulation in what sense that you
know I don't know whether the fact that
I'm talking to you is the real thing or
it's some imagination virtual reality I
don't know there are times when you know
suddenly I wonder is this body but I
don't do often go into that kind of a
trance-like State
I'm not seriously into meditation and
things like that and then go into this
state of elevation or whatever you know
so of course sometimes some people say
maybe I don't have enough emotional
intelligence I think you're very
friendly I think you seems pretty good
pretty good vibes right now do you think
there's a designer of the world that we
live well I don't know I mean I'm I'm
not really a believer in God and things
like that so I guess I can settle for
the evolutionary theory rather than the
Big Bang which is a creationist kind of
okay a way of looking at the world and
how it came about and last question is
what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing in the world
oh wow nature and yeah I mean I love
traveling and you know not just going to
museums but also wide-open spaces in the
mountains and things like that so and of
course there is beauty in algorithms
also absolutely yeah yes so I mean yeah
are two very interesting extreme side of
the mountains and Algar
music and all those things although my
own talent is not in painting things or
singing or dancing over the world but I
appreciate you know visiting museums and
looking at artwork as well as going to
concerts even two evenings ago I was at
my daughter's music teachers schools
25th anniversary program so the Fine
Arts is something that I do appreciate
but it's not that I can appreciate all
kinds of Fine Arts and my experience has
been more or less defined by what I grew
up with back in India and so I
appreciate much more South Indian
classical dance and classical music of
from the southern part of India so I
don't have as much appreciation in any
intrinsic way for western music although
both my kids have done Western violin
for a long long time and I've heard a
little bit of the South Indian Tamil and
Carnatic music genre not sick oh yeah
yeah so I'm at a mo but Carnatic music
spans more than one state and so yes yes
there are lots of Tamil singers and my
own son learned both Carnatic violin and
Karnataka as well as my daughter I think
it makes you smarter so he he both kids
have wide-ranging interests yes more
they started in the university - what
they did though outside of the
university or smart dad smart kids well
my mom is the one who is even more
responsible for the kids doing all this
artsy stuff in where I stayed out of
their hair and let them do these things
but I you know encourage them by
attending concerts and things like that
but I stuff luck with raising them into
this complex world that we have today
yes
Paul I am having fun and thank you so
much for any eight-and-twenty food so
they're not any more kids
they have kids and then you have to deal
with these and grandkids into the world
oh gosh
so Mon thank you so much for coming out
to the show this was an absolute blast
everybody thank you for tuning in if you
guys had a good time make sure to give
us a comment below with your thoughts
subscribe like the video share the
content with other people go and tell to
people what you learned they'll tell to
people and we'll continue talking about
the importance of especially relation
with the data that were currently
accessing how we're actually on how
we're modeling it how blockchains
affecting that this is all very
important technology important coming
things to communicate with each other
create with this content go and make
videos about it go write about it
support us on patreon so we can continue
coming a cool places like the blockchain
economic forum and doing cool interviews
like this thank you everyone very much
much love peace thank you thank you and
if they want to follow me they can look
at Twitter WeChat and so on with ID
being ste
mo h KN SE e mo H a and C Mohan we will
also have that linked in the bio for you
so check it out below go and follow si
Mohan much love everyone thank you bye
bye